[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
SIMIDELE ADEAGBO: Thank you.
I'm always really biased.
That's one of my absolute
favorite Nike commercials.
[LAUGHING]
But it's pretty
brilliant I think.
So thank you for the
great introduction.
And as you saw in that video,
it's all about being first.
About a year ago,
I did something
that no other African
or black woman had ever
dared to do before.
And so I'd like to start with
a description of skeleton.
We just saw a little
bit of it in the video,
but I don't ever assume that
anyone knows what skeleton is.
Because you get a lot of
definitions when you say,
I do the sport of skeleton,
and people get confused.
So I always like
to start with that.
So with millions of people from
all around the world watching,
I dared to do the sport of
skeleton, which is essentially
you going down, headfirst, at
80 miles an hour on a frozen ice
track with your face
just inches from the ice.
Who's signing up for that?
And that's essentially
the sport of skeleton.
And it goes a little
something like this.
I'll just describe
it a bit further.
So you first sprint on
ice for about 30 meters--
yes, I said, on ice
for about 30 meters
before you dive onto your tummy
onto something called a sled.
So you kind of do like a little
Superman dive onto your sled.
And the sled is
actually, essentially,
a tray about the size
of a large suitcase.
So about this long.
Once you're on the
sled, just imagine
being on a giant, frozen,
water slide with massive twists
and turns.
And you're going about as
fast as your car goes down
the freeway.
Yeah, that fast.
So once you're navigating
your way down the track,
you have no safety belt, and
you have no braking mechanism.
And your heart is pretty much
beating faster and faster
with every turn that
you're going down.
And also, your vision
gets a little blurry
because you're going so fast.
And for about 60
seconds, it's just
you, the ice, and your sled
trying to get across the finish
line as quickly as possible.
Now, did I mentioned that
I did this voluntarily?
[LAUGHING]
And I did.
And so, as the intro
said, I made history.
This time last year, I was in
PyeongChang, South Korea making
history as the first
Nigerian to ever compete
in the Winter Olympics.
I also made history as the
first black and African woman
to compete in the sport of
skeleton at the Olympics.
Now, this all sounds
wonderful, but you
might be wondering, outside
of the amazing pizza that's
available at the
Olympic Village--
and it was very, very
good, by the way--
why would I, a then 36-year-old,
mid-level professional,
working at the time at one of
the world's most recognizable
brands--
I was working at Nike--
with a fancy job title,
decide and choose
to put all that aside and
go on a 100 day journey
to pursue the Olympics?
Well for me, it was all
about shifting the narrative.
And this is super important
because this was basically
the driving force,
the motivating force,
that led me to do what I did.
Shifting the narrative
was very important
because my journey was
inspired by the fact
that I discovered that no
African or black woman had ever
competed in the sport of
skeleton at the Olympics.
And I thought, wow, we have
over a billion people in Africa
and there's not been one
person that has done this?
And I recognized an
opportunity, at that point,
to shift the narrative of
what was possible coming
from the continent of Africa.
So Africa is very
severely underrepresented
at the Winter Olympics.
So I don't know
if any of you guys
watched the Olympics last
year, did anyone get a chance,
check me sleighing?
Yes.
You only saw eight countries
that were there from Africa.
And that was historic, right?
Eight countries.
Africa has 54 countries, though.
So there's still quite
a lot of work to do.
And it makes sense.
Obviously, I mean, the
conditions in Africa--
we don't have a lot
of winter climates.
Also, the facilities
aren't there.
And also, it's really
expensive to do these sports.
But I wanted to show people
that despite these barriers,
anything is possible.
That anybody could do anything.
And I wanted to
shift the narrative
of what people
have come to expect
from the continent of Africa.
And so that's why I
went on the journey.
And ultimately, for
me, it was about
inspiring the next generation
to dream without limits.
And so that's what I really
want to talk to you guys,
today, about is my journey
shifting the narrative.
I want to share with you what
that journey looked like, some
of the lessons that I learned.
Because I believe that--
I mean, I'm pretty special,
but I'm not that special.
I am just a regular
person just like you,
who had the desire to
do something different
and make a choice to
do something about it.
I saw an opportunity
where I thought
that I could solve and
use my gifts and talents
to do something about it.
So let's talk about shifting the
narrative and what that means.
And also, in your
lives, everyday lives,
whether it's in your
personal life or your career,
there are opportunities
all around us
to shift the narrative.
And what this journey
has really taught
me is that we all have the power
to take those steps to do it.
So I hope that what I share
with you, you can take
and you can apply.
And we're all going to be
shifting the narratives.
I actually like to call it
sleighing the narrative.
Forget shifting,
I like to sleigh.
So-- but first, I
want to just give you
a little context as to who I am
and what led me to this point
in my life.
So this is my birth picture.
And I wanted to start here
because, actually, for me
as a Nigerian, the name is
really important in my culture.
I am from the Yoruba
culture in Nigeria.
AUDIENCE: Woo.
SIMIDELE ADEAGBO: Yeah.
We got some Nigerians?
Yes.
It's really, really important.
And in my culture, children
get named-- babies get named
seven days after they're born.
And that's because
it's really important
to understand the circumstances
around a child's birth.
If you hear the
name, you can hear
the story of what was going on
with the family or the child
at that particular
point in time.
So my full name is Simidele and
that means accompany me home.
And you can see right
here, I was born
in Toronto, Ontario, Canada.
So yes, I have multiple
passports, which helps.
But I'm Nigerian to the bone.
But my name is Simidele
because I was born in Canada
and I was essentially
accompanying my parents
back home to Nigeria.
So a couple months
after I was born,
my parents went back to Nigeria
and I accompanied them home.
And it's interesting because
that was actually a sneak peek
into kind of how my life
ended up playing out.
But this is where
my story starts.
So I lived in Nigeria
until I was six years old.
And after that, then my
family moved to the US
and we moved to Canada, as well.
And I grew up in different
parts of the US and Canada,
until seventh grade.
I moved to Louisville, Kentucky.
And that's where, for the
most part, that I grew up.
In seventh grade is also where
I pretty much discovered sport.
And I started playing sports
on a pretty active level.
I played a number
of different sports,
including those that you
see there, track and field.
I played field hockey,
volleyball, basketball.
You name it, I played
it and I loved it.
And this is where the athlete
in me really started to arise.
But the sport that kind
of stuck with me most
is track and field.
And this is where
I really excelled.
And this is what I call
my original Olympic dream.
I had a vision that I
would be at the Olympics.
The sun would be shining, and
I would be jumping in sand.
And I came really
close to that vision.
In college, I was a
four-time All-American
at the University of Kentucky.
And those that don't know
what an All-American is,
it means you're really good.
[LAUGHING]
It means you are one of the
top athletes in the nation
in the United States.
So that was quite an honor.
And I felt that I had a lot
of potential to really make it
at the Olympic level.
So I tried out for two Olympic
teams in 2004, as well as 2008.
And I came very, very close
to making those teams,
but just didn't quite make it.
And that, obviously, was
a huge disappointment.
I had spent years of my
life devoted to this goal
and falling short was
very disappointing.
But that's when I
realized that, hey, you
can give something your best and
maybe you don't quite make it.
And then you keep going.
And so for me, I decided
to call it quits.
I hung up my spikes, and I
retired for about 10 years.
I moved on with my life.
And this is actually where
my shifting the narrative
story really begins.
So I had a job opportunity
and I had the chance
to move to South Africa--
Johannesburg, South Africa
about 5 and 1/2 years ago.
And it was awesome
because before that, I was
living in Beaverton, Oregon.
And if you've ever
lived there, you
know that that was a come up
for me to move to South Africa.
So I was quite
pleased with that.
[LAUGHING]
And so my shifting the
narrative journey really
begins here, because
this is where I
started noticing a disconnect.
I started noticing that there
was a disconnect between what
the world sees and
perceives of Africa,
and what I was experiencing
everyday living
and working on the continent.
So this picture,
here, is, to me,
kind of representative of
what the world typically sees
when they think about Africa.
To me, this picture represents
despair, hopelessness, death,
disease, destruction.
Those are the stories
and the narratives
that get told about Africa.
And it just wasn't matching up
with what I was seeing, living
and working in Johannesburg.
What I was seeing was
beauty, vibrancy, resilience,
innovation.
And I was starting to know more
about the business context,
as well, because I
was working there.
So I started hearing stats
like, Africa's got the youngest
consumers in the world.
The average age of an
African is 19 years old.
Africa also has 6 out of 10
of the world's fastest growing
economies.
Also, Africa has more
than 400 companies
that are driving more than
$1 billion of revenue.
And these are stats that
we don't hear about.
That is not the story that
we are told about Africa.
So that started getting
me curious and interested.
So I was there in
a corporate sense,
but I started getting a
sense that maybe there
was more that I could do
in my personal capacity
to shift the narrative.
And oh, yeah, I love to travel.
So while I've been
in South Africa
for the last 5 and
1/2 years, I've
made it my personal
agenda, my personal mission
to travel to as many African
countries as possible.
So here's a picture
from Dakar, Senegal.
This is the Renaissance statue.
And I went there a few
years back to visit.
And I was just shocked that I
had never heard of this statue
before.
It's about 50 meters tall.
And it's taller than the
Christ the Redeemer in Rio.
It's taller than the
Statue of Liberty.
And it's really dope, as
well, because it represents
African freedom and independence
and the story behind it
is really, really deep.
And I was shocked that this
beautiful, beautiful statue
that's sitting, here,
right on the continent,
I had never heard of.
I'd never seen in a magazine.
And it's taller than
all of these statues
that we hear about all the time.
So I started also kind of
taking those kind of things
into consideration.
And then, of course, you
have some holiday time
and you get to go
to the beaches.
This is a picture from Zanzibar.
And you can see there, it's
beautiful white sand beaches
with turquoise waters.
The waters and the beach
setting that we all dream of.
This is right here on
the continent of Africa.
And by the way, this
is just one of many.
And again, these are not the
stories that we hear about
or people talk about
when it comes to Africa.
So for me, that five years
that I've been in South Africa
has really impacted me.
And this is the
conversations that I
started having with myself
and started asking myself that
well, it's great that I'm here.
I'm working in my
corporate capacity.
But I really feel
a personal calling
to do something in my capacity
to help shift the narrative.
So-- and now, I had this
opportunity to do that.
And so now begins the
part where I actually
started shifting the narrative.
And this is where
I want to share
with you some of the lessons
that I learned along the way.
So there's three
key things that I've
learned as I've talked
about and experienced
shifting the narrative.
It starts with a choice.
So my choice started
when, in December of 2016,
a friend of mine sent
me a link to an article
about the Nigerian
women's bobsled team.
And like most people,
I probably had only
heard of bobsled through what?
The movie "Cool Runnings."
Exactly.
[LAUGHING]
And that was my only
point of reference.
But there they were.
These three women who said
they wanted to make history.
They wanted to become the
first African bobsled team
to go to the Olympics.
And I immediately was hooked.
And given what I just
mentioned about what
I was seeing and
starting to understand
and seeing the disconnect in the
narratives that were being told
and the reality of
what I was living,
I knew instinctively,
immediately that this
was my opportunity and my way
to play a part in shifting
the narrative.
But-- big problem--
I know nothing about bobsled.
What's going to happen?
So I did what everyone would do.
I hit these girls
up on Instagram.
[LAUGHING]
And I reached out and I said,
hey, I just saw this article.
And I'm super interested.
Are you looking
for team members?
Because in my mind, bobsled
is a four person sport,
and there were
only three of them.
So they quickly
corrected me and let
me know that actually,
for women, it's
still only a two women sport.
And we actually have our
team and an alternate.
So yeah, you're good.
So that was the
immediate response.
And at that point, I
though, OK, well, maybe that
wasn't my opportunity
to shift the narrative.
And I kind of just went
on minding my business.
And then a few months later,
I saw this on their Instagram.
And that dream was reborn.
And that opportunity and that
choice to shift the narrative
was reborn.
So this was the post that was
posted by the Nigerian Bobsled
and Skeleton Federation.
It was for a tryout
in Houston, Texas.
So the Federation
is based in Houston.
Anybody who's been
to Houston probably
knows there's lots
of Nigerians there.
So our founder was
actually based in Houston.
And so that's why the
tryouts were there.
So I saw this post on
Instagram about two weeks
before the actual tryouts.
And I really, really
wasn't sure what
to do with this information
because I knew, OK,
maybe they already had
their team in place.
And I thought, OK, I don't know.
I live in Johannesburg.
Am I supposed to fly
to Houston for this?
And then, I just also wasn't
sure what am I trying out for?
Is it for the Olympics?
Is it for the next Olympics?
And then, if you see
there in the fine print,
it says 18 to 35.
And just a week before I
saw this post, I turned 36.
[LAUGHING]
Dang it.
But this is where
the choice really
the important part and the
big first step in shifting
the narrative.
No narrative gets
shifted accidentally.
You have to make a
deliberate choice.
So even though I had all these
things I wasn't sure about.
I had all of these fears.
Would I be good enough?
Do I know anything
about bobsled?
What does this mean?
Am I too old?
I had to make a
choice because I was
that passionate about
shifting the narrative
and it starts with
that first step.
And that's making the choice.
So I decided two weeks
before this tryout
that I was going
to go and try out.
And by the way, I was still in
my 10-year retirement when I
got--
when I saw this post.
That also was one of my fears.
I had not competed at a
high level in 10 years.
So was I ready?
I didn't know.
But I was willing to find out.
And I felt that I had
absolutely nothing to lose.
So I traveled to Houston.
I flew all the way
from Johannesburg.
And I was at the
tryout for one day.
There were three
things you had to do.
You had to do a 45-meter sprint.
You had to do a
standing long jump.
And then you had to
do a shot put throw.
And I felt like, if
I can just make it
through without
pulling a muscle, that
is a win at 36 years old.
So I felt I could make it.
And so I used the two weeks
between when I booked my ticket
and when I went to try to
get my muscles back in shape.
And I made it through.
And not only did
I make it through,
but I made it through
enough to make the team.
And I was invited back
to a camp the next month.
So making that choice and
doing that first step was huge.
So the next part of shifting
the narrative, once I decided
to make that choice, it was
then about how was I going
to step into this new world?
What does this new
world look like for me?
And again, I knew nothing
about this new world.
So when I showed up to the camp
that I was then invited to,
it was a lot of learning.
I had no idea about anything and
I felt just like this picture.
I felt like a fish out of water.
And that's when I actually made
the transition from a focus
to bobsled to now a
focus to skeleton.
One, because at that camp
it was confirmed that hey,
the team is already
in place for bobsled.
And somebody actually
suggested, hey,
would you be
interested in skeleton?
And like many people, I
said, what's skeleton?
And when they showed
me, I said, huh?
And I didn't think I would
be interested either.
But after I made my choice,
and said, I'm interested,
my choice was really about
shifting the narrative.
So whether the vehicle--
literally, the vehicle was a
bobsled or a skeleton sled,
I stayed focused on
that choice that I made.
And that was to
shift the narrative.
But I still had to
start from somewhere.
And I was starting
below ground zero.
Because this is a sport
where nobody from my country
knew anything about it.
I couldn't ask anyone from my
country, my family, my friends.
No one could help me.
And so I had to rely on
the community of people
to try to figure out how I
could somehow fit in and not
feel like an imposter, which was
very difficult because I looked
very different than anybody
that was in the sport.
And there I was with my
beads, with my braids,
with my Davido blasting
in my Beats headphones.
And I was just kind
of somebody that was
trying to just figure it out.
And there was a whole
new language as well
that was spoken.
All kinds of technical terms
that I didn't know about,
equipment things, and I had
to learn a whole new culture,
essentially.
But what I realized in that
space was that although I'm
trying to shift
the narrative, it
was really important
to stay true to myself.
And the more I
stayed true to myself
that would just help
me build my confidence
and know that I could do it.
I always thought about
why I was doing it.
The reason that I was doing
it, for the people back home
because this barrier
needed to be broken.
And then, what I
realized is that I
would need to curate what I
wanted the new narrative to be.
And for me, that
was rooted in how
I wanted black women and
African women to be represented.
So I started thinking
about what do
I want to show up looking like
when I do show up in this room
when I'm an imposter.
And nobody's ever
seen anybody like me.
What do I want their
first impression
to be of an African woman?
And I started curating that.
And that was a
head-to-toe curation.
So it started with my braids.
And this was something
super important to me.
First of all, braids are very
convenient and practical,
especially when you
have to wear a helmet.
You saw it in that video.
I'm always wearing a helmet.
So from a practicality
standpoint, it made sense.
But braids to me represented
more than practicality.
Braids were super
important because I just
felt that they represented an
African beauty, specifically,
these braids that you
see in these pictures.
They're called Fulani braids
from a tribe in Nigeria.
And you've seen them.
Stars like Alicia Keys
wears them and other stars.
Well, she did back
in the day anyways.
Where you have two braids
coming down in front and usually
there's beads and things.
And they're decorated.
And I just thought
that if I was going
to be stepping
out into the world
and wanting to
represent what it is
to be a beautiful, intelligent,
strong, black, African woman,
that the braids were an
important crown to that.
And I wanted the world to
see and celebrate that.
And that was all part
of how I could curate
the narrative that I wanted.
Then, the beads.
The beads were really
important to me,
as well, because those
told a deeper story.
For me, the beads
told a deeper story
of the women that
had come before me,
specifically, Venus
and Serena Williams.
These were heroes
of mine growing up.
And I called them the
original trailblazers.
And if you remember,
when they first, first
came out back in the day,
they had those beads.
And those beads were iconic.
And so I wanted to pay homage
to that legacy in some way
by rocking beads.
So up until this day, every
time that you see me compete,
I'm usually wearing those
beads, just to pay homage.
And they're cute, as well.
[LAUGHING]
Don't mind being cute.
Whoop, sorry.
And then, the last piece--
now, we're working my way down
the head-to-toe look--
was then, what are
the little elements
that I could put
into my equipment
to tell a deeper story about
what I wanted the narrative
to be and how I wanted to curate
the narrative of what it means
to be a modern African woman?
And so what you see,
I guess to my left,
is what the back of
my sled looks like.
This is a pattern
that I had designed.
And so, hopefully,
you can see it.
Some people see different
things when they look at it.
But what it is the
continent of Africa,
and you can also see kind of the
silhouette of a woman's face.
So I just felt like
that was super strong.
And it has a deeper
meaning, as well,
because this was a
logo of an organization
that I co-founded
back in Johannesburg
that was all about
women's empowerment
and connecting women and
bringing them together
to elevate them.
So I wanted to
carry that with me
as I was going to PyeongChang.
And then, of course, you
have to have the shoes.
The shoes have to be on point.
And so my good
friends at Nike were
able to design some shoes for me
that spoke to who I truly was.
And that was all part
of the curated narrative
that I wanted to drive.
So you have the green
and white, which
is all about Nigeria colors.
And then they had the date
that I made history, as well
as equality, which really spoke
to kind of equality in sports
because I was doing
something to break barriers.
And so curating is the second
part of one of my lessons
I feel that I've learned
through this journey of how
to shift the narrative.
So first you make the
choice, but then you
have to be really
strategic about how
you curate the new narrative
that you want to drive.
So the third piece
is commitment.
So you've made the choice.
You've now curated
the new narrative.
Now, you have to commit to it.
And so this is me
in PyeongChang.
And PyeongChang was
really a starting point.
I really see it as
a starting point.
Now, I have a
longer-term commitment
to continue to
shift the narrative.
And I've made that commitment
through to the next Olympics
in Beijing 2022.
Narratives typically don't
get shifted overnight.
That's the reality.
So you have to be
committed for however
long that journey takes.
And it's an evolution.
It's always a conversation.
And so I have taken that step.
And there's still tons
of work to be done.
So I mentioned
earlier that Africa
had eight countries,
which represent about 8%
of the total countries that
were at the Winter Olympics.
Europe, as a continent, 52%.
So the gap is still
very, very wide.
And I'm hoping that what
I've done to open the door
will inspire other African
countries to come along,
as well.
And who knows where
we can be by 2022.
The other thing that I'm
going hard at to continue
to shift the narrative is,
it's one thing to participate,
but it's a whole other
thing to be a contender.
So the goal is, by
2022, that the narrative
is shifting from, oh, cute,
the Africans are here--
[LAUGHING]
--to wow, the Africans
are winning medals.
And that's now the next
level of the narrative
that I'm trying to drive.
Norway, just by
themselves, won 39 medals
at the last Winter Olympics.
And the rest of the
European countries
also followed suit with 21.
And Africa had 0.
So the race is on for
which African country
is going to win the first
Winter Olympic medal.
And that's the
commitment that it's
going to take to continue
to shift the narrative
and shift the conversation.
So I think through
my journey, I hope
that you guys have taken from
this that I'm a regular person,
just like everyone else.
But I made the choice
to shift the narrative.
I curated how I wanted that
narrative to be shifted.
And then, I'm continuing
with that commitment
to continue to drive further
growth and development in ways
that people see Africa,
people see black women,
people see what's possible.
There's so many layers to this.
And I'm continuing
to drive change.
And I hope that you guys see
that I'm just a regular person.
And that you can do it, too.
Any narrative that
you want shifted,
whether it's in your personal
life, professional life,
it's possible.
So I hope you're
inspired to do that.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: So I want
to touch on something
you mentioned about
your collegiate career.
So you said, All-American
means pretty good.
But as I understand it, you
have the Kentucky record
for triple jump?
Kind of the best?
And you were also an
Academic All-American.
So how do you balance being
really, really competitive
at two different things?
SIMIDELE ADEAGBO: Yeah.
So, unfortunately,
I have to report
that my records did just
get broken recently,
which was very sad.
But I held them for over 10
years, which is a long time.
But for me, that's
always been how
I've been is to balance both
academics and athletics.
The two have always
gone hand in hand.
At my house--
I don't know-- you
have Nigerian parents?
It was--
SPEAKER: Two of them.
SIMIDELE ADEAGBO: Yes.
[LAUGHING]
It wasn't a choice.
There wasn't an option.
You couldn't do one
without the other.
If the grades were slipping,
athletics were cut.
So I always had to make
sure that I balanced both.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: And was it difficult
to go from track and field,
where, clearly, you were
very knowledgeable and top
of your game, to something
where you didn't even know
were to begin?
That transition from-- when
you go to change the narrative
as a courage for
overcoming some kind
of fear of being an imposter.
Can you dig into that
a little bit for us?
SIMIDELE ADEAGBO: Yeah.
I think-- you know, they
look very foreign, track
and field and skeleton.
But the more I've spent
time in the sport,
I'm now starting to see
more and more similarities.
But when I was new, I didn't
see a lot of similarities.
It was very
terrifying, at first.
But what I did is
actually, what I
mentioned in my talk, which is
really press into my strengths,
and press into myself,
which sounds selfish.
But one thing that I was
able to pick up very quickly
is the 30 meter sprint.
So once I realized that
I was good at that,
I was like I'm going
to do this all day.
So for the first 5, 6
seconds of the race,
I'm actually in the lead,
which was really exciting.
At the Olympics, at a point, you
know, I was in medal position.
But there's the
rest of the track.
So the race is about 60
minutes-- or, yeah, 60 seconds,
sorry.
And so what I'm working
on now to close that gap
is to be a better driver.
So I used my strength.
I operated from a
position of strength.
What am I good at?
The 30 meter sprint.
And I just tried to dominate
that as much as I could.
I had the third best
time at the Olympics.
And so for somebody who
had been in the sport
for about 100 days, I
thought that was pretty good.
So I just always
feel that if you
can operate from a
position of strength,
you're never an imposter.
SPEAKER: Yeah, along
that, in your talk,
you mentioned
changing the narrative
and multiple levels of it,
which I thought was great.
When I was watching
you in the Olympics,
I was listening
to the announcers
speak about that point, about--
from the first-- from the drive
and through the first couple
of time check points,
that you were in the lead.
And that people were sort
of, like, hey, you know,
the Nigerians are here.
Cute.
Oh, wait.
She's starting to
win some events.
And you'd won some
events before that.
Have you noticed a
change in how helpful
some of your competitors
are, as people
start to realize you can become
a better driver easier than you
can just magically get faster?
SIMIDELE ADEAGBO: Yeah.
Yeah, skeleton is
an interesting sport
and people really keep
their cards close to them.
And so yes, as you're
getting better and better
naturally the competition
is not maybe as open.
When you're finishing dead last,
everybody is like, oh, yeah,
maybe try this.
[LAUGHING]
But when you start
showing some promise,
people are a little
bit more secretive.
SPEAKER: You work as a product
marketing manager for Nike
working on campaigns
for you mentioned
like Venus and Serena.
And it's interesting,
now, that's you.
Right?
people, like me are inspired
by you and look to you.
And now, Nike is
making shoes for you.
How has that transition felt?
And has that been weird or--
SIMIDELE ADEAGBO:
It's definitely
been strange because
I was so used
to being on the other side.
So working on campaigns
for other athletes.
And so when the team actually
brought that commercial
and showed me for
the first time,
I just felt so vulnerable
because, you know,
I'm used to being the
one calling the shots.
And saying, OK, we need
to touch on this insight.
You know?
But now the team was
asking me and trying
to dig into how I
feel, to capture
the essence of the emotion
that you saw in that ad.
So it just was a very
different experience.
But it was really cool.
I mean, hey, being a Nike
athlete is never a bad thing.
And I actually have
just recently made
the transition more to
focus on being a Nike
athlete versus working
in the corporate space
because I want to spend more
time doing the work that I'm
doing around shifting
the narrative on a deeper
level as an advocate,
continuing my journey to 2022.
So yeah, it's been
an interesting kind
of relationship being on the
other side as a Nike athlete,
but cool, as well.
SPEAKER: And touching
on advocacy, you
know, it's more than
just doing two things.
You do many things.
So can you tell us a little bit
about the work with the Malala
Foundation and Obama
and what's all that?
SIMIDELE ADEAGBO: Yes.
So this whole skeleton thing
was not planned, like I said.
But what was cool about
it was that I really
realized that my story
somehow inspired other people.
And so I have taken
it very seriously
to use my platform
responsibly, as I call it.
So coming out of the Olympics,
I looked for those opportunities
where I could drive
social impact.
One of them being Malala Fund.
Nigeria is one of Malala
fund's priority countries.
There are more
girls out of school
in that country, in Nigeria,
than anywhere else in Africa.
And so it's a very
serious issue.
And so I thought,
if there's anything
that I can do to bring awareness
and to raise money, I'll do it.
So I've been working closely
with them as an ambassador
to do that.
And then, I was super
excited because I
was selected as one of the
Obama Foundation leaders.
So the Obama Foundation
has started a program,
and I was in the inaugural
class, where they selected 200
leaders from all across Africa.
Leaders who are
creating and driving
change in their communities
and their countries
in all kinds of
different spectrums.
Some in government,
some in sports, like me.
Everybody doing all kinds
of different things.
And so the Obama Foundation
is really working with us
to help amplify all of
the different things
that we're doing and support it.
So that's been cool, as well.
SPEAKER: Awesome.
All right.
I'm going to open it up
to the room for questions.
And we'll take some questions
from the Dory as well.
Do we have a microphone
to pass around?
AUDIENCE: So crazy small world.
My high school big sister,
Seun, is on the team with you.
So I picked that
up on the flyer.
So that was-- if you have any
bad stories about her that I
can [INAUDIBLE], let me know.
My first question is you spoke
a lot about the opportunity
and maybe pressure of
having to kind of define
how the world viewed what
an African woman was, right?
And so I think that's
something very similar
that minorities at
Google experience
in a different light.
It's not due to
athleticism, but you
consider the people
that work at Google
like the best of the best.
And so it kind of presents
this challenge or a task
that is not necessarily--
you're not asked to do it,
but it's kind of required
as a part of your
daily job to think
about how you present yourself
to co-workers and people that
may not have a lot of experience
in dealing with people that
look like you or working with
people that look like you
and that genuinely want to
understand more about others.
But I think that that
can become frustrating.
And especially, as we look at
how black people experience
our company, it's a little bit
different than everyone else.
So for, I guess, the black
women and the black men
in the room that have to
constantly kind of feel
this pressure of wanting to
shift the narrative every day,
what advice do you give
them or what do you
tell them about the
opportunity and privilege that
also presents?
Because it's not just
work, but it's a privilege
to be someone in
that position to be
able to have that opportunity.
So how do you
encourage those folks?
SIMIDELE ADEAGBO: Yeah.
I always look at it as a
position of inspiration
and an opportunity to inspire
through what you're doing.
When you're shifting
the narrative,
there's always going to be
people who don't understand
or are criticizing a
certain group or whatnot.
But I like to flip it, and
people say ignore the critics.
I like to say
inspire the critics.
And so I would just say back
to what I was talking about
I really had fun curating.
I look at it as if I
was working in a museum
and I would want to curate
a beautiful exhibition.
What is that experience
that you want people to have
when they encounter you?
Of course, you can only
represent yourself,
but knowing that, as a
minority group, typically,
like you said, some
people may only
have limited experience
with just you.
And so suddenly you're speaking
for all black people on Earth.
So as you do that, know that
you can only do your best
and try to inspire
as you're doing that
and curate it to
the best that you
can working from a
place of strength
and just showing
how you do things.
AUDIENCE: My question--
I have two questions.
One of them being,
I have a little bit
of insider knowledge.
I was at my alma mater
a couple of weeks ago
and one of the alumni works
at Nike as a category--
I think she's a
category sales manager--
working on the women, focus
on women in emerging markets.
And I found it interesting
that when she mentioned which
markets Nike considers
emerging for women,
Africa wasn't in there at all.
And I just was like--
and we both looked.
And she was like, yeah, I know.
It doesn't make sense.
And I was like, no,
it doesn't make sense.
And so that's one
question as to when
you talk about
shifting a narrative,
obviously, your track is,
for lack of a better term,
is doing that from a
Nike athlete perspective
versus maybe corporate.
What might that look
like in a corporation?
And my second
question really feeds
into that is, how did you sell
that shifting of narrative
and that story and that
brand opportunity to Nike?
Because, yeah,
they sponsored you.
Yes, you're a Nike athlete.
But that wasn't a, hey, I
want to try out for the team
and, you know, this
will be cool and you
know this is a cool thing.
It was, I'm sure, much
more well thought out.
And how did you present
that opportunity?
SIMIDELE ADEAGBO: So
the first question
about kind of the
lack of, I guess,
recognition that
Africa is on the map
is something that
I've personally
found challenging
working on the continent.
And so it's not only
Nike, but there's
a lot of companies who
are just not there yet.
They are not seeing the
potential and the opportunities
that exist in Africa.
I'm really excited
because I just
came from NBA All-Star
Weekend, where the NBA made
this huge announcement
that they're
starting a pro league in Africa
starting next year with 12
pro teams.
And I thought that that
was a huge statement
that they are taking that
step, making an investment
to expand specifically
in Africa.
So I'm hoping more
companies follow suit.
As I mentioned, some of
those stats are just amazing.
I mean, I think people
think of the story
that we typically get.
And they don't know the
opportunities that exist there.
So I'm just hoping that global
companies, more and more,
start seeing the
opportunities within Africa.
And the companies that
are already there,
I think you really, from having
the experience of working
on the continent,
had to do a lot
of internal kind of advocating
to have make sure Africa
has a seat at the table.
It's 2019.
It's sad that that's
still the case.
But it is kind of what
we have to do for now.
And I think if we just keep
pushing and keep pushing,
people are going to
eventually open their eyes
to the opportunities.
So the second question is,
how did I approach Nike?
The funny thing is I
was minding my business.
And-- no, this--
everything happened
so fast, honestly.
So from the time
when I tried out,
like I said, in
August of 2017, I
wasn't really sure at that
point what it would lead to.
So I just snuck away to
Houston for the weekend.
I literally didn't tell anyone.
I think we had like an off
site that Friday that I
was supposed to be there.
And I took the day
and went to Houston.
And because I just wasn't sure.
And I was like, I don't
want to tell anybody,
and then it turns
out to be nothing.
But by the time I got invited
back to the team camp,
I was like, OK, this
could be something.
So I told my boss.
And one thing that I
appreciate about Nike
was that I had their support.
I had my boss's
support from day one.
Even though we didn't
know where it was going,
she said, wow, this is amazing.
If you do end up having a real
shot, you know, this is great.
And I support you 100%.
And so the closer
and closer it got
and the more realistic
that, wow, by-- so by now,
like, by October, it was
starting to look like,
OK, this is actually happening.
And they were in full support.
Now, I never came with like an
agenda or a proposal to say,
hey, you know, can
you do a commercial?
[LAUGHING]
I, at that time,
as an employee, I
was just more worried about
would I have the flexibility
to pursue this opportunity?
And thankfully, I did.
I was able to work remotely
for the first few months.
Then, as it got closer to the
games, I had to take time off.
And Nike was supportive of that.
It was actually the marketing
team, independent of me.
I didn't ask anything.
They thought that my story was
interesting and a story that
needed to be told.
So big kudos to Nike.
I think that was a bold step.
You know, skeleton
is not a sport
that Nike really is
in the business of.
Nike doesn't really do a lot
with winter sports, in general.
But I think they
just were inspired
by the essence of the story and
felt that it needed to be told.
And that happened completely
independently of me.
SPEAKER: Would've been awkward
if you signed with Adidas.
[LAUGHING]
SIMIDELE ADEAGBO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How's it going?
My name's Jonathan.
So I'm originally from Texas.
And one of the reasons I
moved out to California
was because it was easier
for me to be in tech here
than it was in Texas, especially
being an African American.
And I noticed you said you
lived many places in the US.
And also lived in
many places in Africa.
And I'm wondering, just from
your personal experience,
did you find a place or location
where maybe it was easier
for black people
to thrive or become
more successful in careers like
tech or high value careers,
like tech.
Or is it pretty much different
problems, different places?
SIMIDELE ADEAGBO: Yeah,
I would say the latter.
But I actually
think Johannesburg
has been a place where
I really feel like has
a lot of great things about it.
You have a lot of
affluent black people
doing a lot of different
things in different industries.
South Africa now
has a little bit
of a trickier
background because they
are just 20 plus years from
apartheid-- post apartheid.
So that adds some complexities.
But just in terms of
opportunities and everything
like that, it's
very diverse there.
And I've enjoyed living there.
I would say it's probably,
yeah, the most diverse place
that I've lived.
I mean, Portland, Oregon
wasn't really diverse.
But I also grew up in
Louisville, Kentucky.
I lived in Canada.
So I think Johannesburg has
that perfect blend of diversity
and opportunities
for everyone, really.
SPEAKER: Your baby brother
is changing some narratives,
as well, right?
SIMIDELE ADEAGBO:
Yeah, a little bit.
[LAUGHING]
SPEAKER: For those Googlers
who are members of dev color
is founded by Makinde, who
is Simi's younger brother.
So yeah.
I'm going to go to
the Dory and see if we
can take one Dory question.
The question is, "Your
story is pretty interesting.
Have you considered
selling it to Hollywood?
Making a movie?"
SIMIDELE ADEAGBO: Well--
SPEAKER: I could
play assistant coach.
[LAUGHING]
Just give me one line.
SIMIDELE ADEAGBO: Well, I do
think there are opportunities
to tell the story
and I've considered
what the best platforms
to do that would
be, whether it's through
books or movies, et cetera.
So my agent is waiting.
If they know somebody, tell
them to call my people.
SPEAKER: Yes.
Where's the next question?
Right here.
AUDIENCE: So growing up--
so I'm from Cameroon.
We're neighbors.
And I learned figure
skating when I grew up here.
And I was wondering, you
talked about the talent
that's in Africa, both on the
continent, but also people
whose families have
immigrated here.
How do we connect people with
those interests or passions
with that opportunity both on
the continent and also here?
SIMIDELE ADEAGBO: Yeah.
I think that's a huge thing
because the diaspora is so big.
Are you asking specifically
about in winter sports
or just in general
connecting them?
SPEAKER: In general.
SIMIDELE ADEAGBO: Yeah,
I don't know the answer
to that-- the best
answer to that.
But I definitely see
that it needs to happen.
A couple of years ago, I went
to the Harvard Business School
Africa Business Conference.
And they had a ton of people,
mostly from the diaspora,
talking about some of
these topics of what's
happening on the continent.
How we can shift the narrative.
And I thought it was a
lot of good dialogue.
But I thought what was
missing was connecting it back
to those that are
actually in Africa.
I happened to have traveled
there from Johannesburg.
But outside of me,
I don't think there
were many people who were
coming from Africa to attend
that conference.
So I think there definitely
needs to be those spaces.
And maybe digital--
we are at Google--
is the space to find
those connections.
Because obviously physical
is not always feasible
for different reasons.
But I think the
more and more we can
have those opportunities to
connect, the better that we can
lift and elevate
Africa, as a whole,
whether you're in the
diaspora or actually
living on the continent.
So--
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER: And so for
those of us that
want to continue following
your story, like, what's
the website, social media?
Like, what's the best way?
SIMIDELE ADEAGBO:
Thank you, because I
did forget to put it on here.
So all my handles are
SimiSleighs, S-I-M-I.
And then I spell
sleighs, S-L-E-I-G-H-S.
That's the way you do
sleighs in the sport.
SPEAKER: Santa.
SIMIDELE ADEAGBO:
Yes, like Santa.
So SimiSleighs.com and then all
Instagram, Twitter, Facebook,
is @SimiSleighs.
SPEAKER: Awesome.
And request-- a slightly
selfish request for me is it's
possible to buy, you
know, LeBron jerseys
and such in women's
sizes, it's not
as easy to buy, like, say, you
know, Rapinoe jerseys or Simi
jerseys in men's sizes.
So when you get back
to Nike, if you could
put that little request in.
SIMIDELE ADEAGBO:
We'll put the word in.
SPEAKER: I'm a 2XL.
[LAUGHING]
SIMIDELE ADEAGBO: We've
got to get you on a sled,
though, first.
SPEAKER: Oh.
Oh.
It might-- it might--
it might break.
How thick is the ice?
Thank you so much.
This has been fascinating.
And you know, we've really
enjoyed watching your story
and hearing about how we can
kind of think about changing
the narrative in our own lives.
You've done it in several
different contexts.
And I think it's
something that all of us
are trying to do here, as well.
So that's-- this has
really been great.
SIMIDELE ADEAGBO: Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]